thankfully Naruto took after his parents
and had a caring teacher in iruka Sensei
who was a positive role model for the
young Shinobi and thanks to those
factors Naruto grew up into the person
that we know and love embodying the
values of friendship and teamwork plus
it also helped that he's a Reincarnation
of a really nice guy but what if Naruto
hadn't had that great influence in his
life after all iruka's own parents were
killed by the nine-tailed fox that lives
inside Naruto and so he had every reason
to despise Naruto just like everyone
else in the village leading Naruto to go
down a very dark path similar to Sasuke
so how would the world of Naruto look
different if our hero had become a
villain what if Naruto had joined the
katsuki well first off we have a pretty
good idea of what happens when a kid
with the power of a tail beast is
completely maladjusted and has a
horrible upbringing just take a look at
Gara here when we first meet him he is
contrasted with Naruto because their
stories are so similar both both of them
are chinchuriki the term used for
someone who has a tail beast sealed
inside of them both of them had a very
lonely and very painful childhood
however Gara did lack a relationship
like the one that Naruto had with iruka
Sensei instead Yara had a relationship
with his uncle Yasha Maru the two were
very close but yashamaru was ordered by
gara's own father to assassinate him and
so after being betrayed by the only
person that he ever loved gotta fell
deeper into darkness hatred and violence
honestly can't really blame him I think
I do the same if my own Uncle tried to
assassinate me on the orders of my
father however there's one major
difference Gara was still used as a pawn
and Weapon by the hidden Sand Village
Naruto's Powers though were restricted
at all caused by the hidden Leaf Village
the ninthians Kurama was simply too
powerful to contain after all as
everyone knows the more Tales you have
the stronger you are and so instead of
being able to use these powers for goods
Naruto tapping into the Beast chakra
risked unleashing the nine-tailed fox to
attack the village once again and so
this time when Orochimaru and the Sand
Village attacked the hidden Leaf during
the tuning exams things would play out
extremely differently because in Naruto
as we know the Sand Village sent their
greatest weapon gotta to attack the
hidden Leaf in order to improve their
own economic conditions I mean they
could have just instituted a higher
capital gains tax but go off I guess so
thankfully Naruto was there to go head
to head with gotta eventually causing
the fellow chinturiki to have a change
of heart in our timeline though Naruto
won't be the one to influence Gara it
will be the other way around in this
case the hidden levion such as Kakashi
and gai will ultimately be able to Stave
of gara's attack even though he has the
power of shukaku on his side and this is
of course especially true with jiraya
one of the legendary sunning gets
involved in the fight as well after all
the natural weakness of sand is totes
obviously however Naruto will see how
powerful Gada is when when he utilizes
the strength of the Beast Within him and
he will see just how feared he is by his
own village and siblings he'll see how
the Sand Village will bend to his will
in order to avoid angering God up and so
knowing that he can't be loved by the
citizens of konoha Naruto might take
another path here being feared he'll
start becoming much more aggressive
towards his fellow classmates and
villagers and won't fear tapping more
recklessly into kuruma's chakra to
enhance his own strength and really the
only danger is Kurama convincing Naruto
to undo the seal and Unleash the Beast
however I'm going to say that he won't
give in to kurama's temptation to
release him because Naruto will want to
control that power all for himself and
so in our new timeline instead of
staying in the hiddenly village as a
member of Team 7 Naruto will actually be
pushed away after being rejected by the
citizens of the village he'll abandon
his home and run away and in an
inversion of the Sasuke rescue Arc we
can still see these two faded Rivals
compete against each other once again
and so this time instead of aying asking
for his replacement body this time
Orochimaru could seek out Naruto yeah
Sasuke has the Sharingan but it's clear
that Orochimaru would be very interested
in the immense powers of Kurama and so
this time the konoa Shinobi would try to
retrieve Naruto from The Sound 4 leading
to a familiar showdown between Naruto
and Sasuke however there are two
differences this time firstly Sasuke
would be missing his curse mark and on
top of that Naruto would be way more
willing to tap into kuruma's chakra and
be way more aggressive and therefore I
think Naruto would absolutely stomp
Sasuke in their battle this time however
just like Sasuke Naruto would soon
realize that he's being used by
Orochimaru and would abandon his side in
order to achieve his own goals and it
just so happens too that there is an
organization that specifically on the
lookout for jinchuriki that's of course
the Akatsuki and Naruto would already be
somewhat aware of this organization too
first Orochimaru was temporarily aligned
with the group and more importantly he
had encountered Itachi and kizame
previously as well and since Naruto's
biggest rival in konoha was Sasuke it
makes sense that Naruto might join up
with Itachi after all the enemy of your
enemy is your friend and for Naruto the
Akatsuki would allow him to enact his
revenge against the hiddenly village who
had treated him very poorly throughout
his entire life now as you might
remember the Akatsuki organization was
originally formed to promote peace in
the Shinobi world and in a very Twisted
way that's actually still the ultimate
goal of it when we meet it in the story
it's just that they're like super bad at
it considering that their whole
recruitment process is based on how evil
the candidates are they're basically
working as mercenaries for various
villages in order to gain wealth but
they're also in the business of
collecting tailed beasts why well that's
because the tailed beasts are basically
the Ultimate Weapon in the Naruto world
they're the equivalent to weapons of
mass destruction unleashing a tailed
beast on a village might well be like
launching a nuclear warheads and So
based basically the leader of the
Akatsuki nagato wants to obtain each of
the tailed beasts so that he can conquer
all of the world's Villages and stop
them from engaging in wars with one
another by force and in Shippuden we see
that the Akatsuki come into Focus as the
main antagonists of the series they
target the shinsuriki within each of the
villages in order to steal their tailed
beast chakra for example daira captures
Gara and the Akatsuki steal his tail
beast killing the newly crowned kazakage
thankfully Grand machio was able to
sacrifice her life to resurrect Gara but
it was a very close call with a hint of
deus ex machina I guess however in this
timeline Gara likely won't have gone
down so easily since Naruto never talked
no jutsued him after the tune in exams
Gara would still be very much filled
with the violence in Malice giving him
more of an advantage against and so
during the battle in the real series
Gara has to use up a lot of his sand and
chakra in order to save the Village from
one of datara's massive explosions but
in this timeline he'd have no reason to
care about saving the villagers and
would be able to dedicate his full
strength to fighting the explosive clay
user but luckily the Akatsuki would have
a trick up their sleeve which is their
new member Naruto Uzumaki the only
question is when Naruto knocked on the
Akatsuki door looking to join why
wouldn't their leader nagato simply take
his tail beast right then and there well
first off there is the fact that Naruto
is nagato's distant cousin and a fellow
member of the Uzumaki Clan but we also
have a feeling that nagato isn't a type
to get too sentimental about Family Ties
here also more important is the fact
that Naruto harnesses the power of the
Ninetales remember the more Tales a
beast has the more powerful it is which
means Naruto has more chakra potential
than any other of the chinchuriki so if
Naruto was willing to join the
organization he's practically
tailor-made for hunting down the
remaining ones the only question really
is would Naruto realize the natural
endpoint which was of course that after
the rest of the tail bees were captured
they would simply do the same to him
well as we all oh no Naruto is not the
smartest although there's also an
argument to be made that if he was
working with the Akatsuki anyways they
could still use his Beast as a weapon of
mass destruction without having to strip
it from him physically so nagato's plan
could still work though of course we
also have to consider Toby's plans too
and madala's plan and so on and so forth
but we'll save that for a little bit
later therefore where did I would likely
Fall against a still evil Godda Naruto
would succeed the only question is would
they still strip Gara of the tailed
beast or would the organization just
recruit Gara as well in this timeline I
mean just like Naruto Gara would want
revenge against his village and would
thrive in an organization like the
Akatsuki that would allow him to Channel
all of his violent impulses into
mercenary missions and so with Gara in
Naruto as the newest team of the
Akatsuki taking out the remaining
jinchuriki would be pretty much a piece
of cake most of them were easily
obtained by the Akatsuki as they existed
therefore with the strength of two
additional chinturiki on their side
they'd have no problem collecting all of
the tailed beasts well all of the tail
beasts except one that is what they
wouldn't have considered is killer bee
of course now killer bee the right-hand
man to that haikage is known as a
perfect chinchuriki instead of being at
odds with the powers inside of him he
has an actual relationship with the
a-tailed Beast Yuki instead of vying for
power and control with the monster the
two can actually work and sing together
to become even stronger he can even
undergo a massive tailed beast
transformation it is unknown whether
tail beast chakra has any effects on his
rap skills though however even with such
great control over the a Tails though
it's very unlikely that he could
actually contend with all of the members
of the Akatsuki even without complete
control over Kurama Naruto's chakra is
overwhelming and he'd have backup from
the likes of Gara Itachi pain and other
absolute powerhouses and so with Naruto
as an Akatsuki member this criminal
organization would achieve their goal of
capturing every tail beast however
nagato didn't account for the traitor in
their midst Toby AKA obitochia as well
as black zetsu have been manipulating
things behind the scenes for ages even
before the Akatsuki were even forged and
while nagato may have been content with
Gara and Naruto just utilizing their
tail beast as chinchuriki that wouldn't
work for Toby's plan you see his goal
was to reunite all of the nine-tailed
beasts into their original form the
immensely powerful ten tales and though
it would be a true battle Toby and
tetsetsos would likely be able to use
deception to catch Gara and or Naruto
individually off guard in order to
capture their beasts and so with these
Toby would be able to resurrect marada
but in turn kage or Suzuki would also be
summoned as well and whereas in the
original series Naruto and Sasuke were
able to combine their powers in order to
barely overcome this threat to the
planet Sasuke would be the last line of
defense against the infinite tsukoyomi
and the harvesting of all humans into a
chakra food for the old Suzuki's
enjoyment so what if Naruto had joined
yakatsuki well it wouldn't be good in
fact Naruto joining would spell the
destruction of the entire Shinobi world
so remember to thank a teacher today
because without iruka Sensei it would
have been the end of the world also if
you're interested in one piece as well
you can check out what would have
happened if Luffy had become a Marine
right here thanks for watching